elle
non
les internes et les chefs de clinique
ont choisi hier l'affrontement
aujourd'hui ils sont désavoués par
l'ordre des médecins
une équipe de fr3 rentre tout juste
d'albanie leurs témoignages exclusifs
sur le calme apparent et la chape de
plomb qui pèse sur la population
l'azerbaïdjan toujours sous tension
après l'attaqué d'un convoi militaire
par des azéri des manifestants turcs se
massent à la frontière la plume juge
l'éguille c'est ce soir robert sabatier
qui pose son oeil affûté sur le défilé
chanel
bonsoir bonsoir claude evin bonsoir vous
êtes le ministre de la solidarité de la
santé de la protection sociale vous êtes
évidemment très attentifs à la garde des
internes et chefs de clinique
leurs représentants sont reçus en ce
moment même par vos collaborateurs au
ministère alors les dernières
informations à tout d'abord le dialogue
n'est pas rompu puisque nous continuons
de discuter et d'écouter les
préoccupations des jeunes médecins il
est évident qu'au ministre de la santé
je suis attentif aux préoccupations de
ces jeunes médecins
mais toutes les réponses ne sont pas au
ministère de la santé elles sont aussi
dans la discussion qui se poursuit entre
les caisses de sécurité sociale et les
syndicats de médecins
la médecine libérale en france et je
crois qu'il est important de revenir
rapidement sur ce point c'est pas le
ministère qu ils l'organisent
elle s'organise librement c'est de la
médecine libérale entre les caisses et
les syndicats de médecins rien les
caisses ont fait une avancée et je m'en
réjouis
oui mais votre sentiment sur la médecine
libérale nous intéressera je vous
propose avant d'aborder le fond du
problème de faire le point sur la
situation dans les hôpitaux à paris en
france à paris tout d'abord marie odile
pas niaise et olivier oddi jets se sont
rendus dans deux hôpitaux pour enfants
et ils ont tenté de savoir si la grève
des urgences avait des conséquences sur
l'accueil des patients reportage
jean-françois 15 ans choc violent la
tête troubles de la vue le lendemain
jovan à 16 mois couverte de plaques
rouges en quelques heures
chutes brûlures intoxication
vomissements avec la grève des urgences
qui va s'occuper de ses enfants
j'étais angoissé mais je me suis dit
comment ça va se passer effectivement
est-ce qu'il va y avoir possibilité de
rencontrer un médecin elle et savoir
exactement ce qu'il a le moindre petit
trou je suis très je panique très très
vite alors pour nous titré que je coure
aux urgences celles qui sont très
inquiétants parce qu'on se demande ce
qu'on peut faire si elle est chose de
grave
je me suis levé j'ai été voir combien de
parents d'hésiter avant de venir
même dans des cas graves peur d'être mal
reçus ou pas reçu du tout pourtant les
blouses blanches sont la pad interne ou
très peu nom des chefs de service qui
ont abandonné et cours à la faculté
recherche mais aussi consultation ou
opération prévue de longue date
assurer les urgences d'abord nous
arrivons à faire face aux urgences sur
un plan médical
mais je ne sais pas combien de temps
nous pourrons tenir il est évident que
c'est tel type de mouvement ne doit pas
durer car sinon la sécurité des enfants
seraient danger la sécurité des enfants
pourrait être en jeu demain la grève des
internes et des chefs de clinique
continue pas de problème pour les
urgences mais le reste de l'hôpital
tourne au ralenti quelle est la
situation dans les autres villes de
france nous avons choisi deux d'entre
elles marseille et rouen
nous allons retrouver en direct nos
confrères de la 3f girard vous êtes à
l'hôpital marseille nord pen a été
l'ampleur de la grève ben écoutez paul
c'est une grave évidemment très suivi
qui est suivi d'ailleurs depuis d'hier
puisque les marseillais et les internes
marseillais les chefs de clinique à sion
commencé la grève depuis un peu plus tôt
que les autres
c'est une grève qui est probablement
quand même un petit peu moins dur qu'à
paris c'est à dire par exemple pascal
gires valley vous devez vous inquiète la
présidente de l'association des internes
c'est une grève qui ne touche pas les
urgences contrairement aux autres villes
de france
non il faut mettre il faut faire une
mise au point à marseille les urgences
sont assurées par des internes qui sont
réquisitionnés la grève porte sur les
soins non urgents
mais les patients sont accueillis aux
urgences alors dans les autres services
bien évidemment ça fonctionne
un petit peu moins bien ce qui fait dire
à certains que les malades sont parfois
ici à marseille pris en otage qu'est ce
que vous leur répondez jean pierre
aubert vous piètre le le leader des
chefs de clinique dans le mouvement
actuel leader est un bien grand mot
non les malades ne sont pas prises en
otage nous ne voulons absolument pas que
les malades soient prises en otages la
nous sommes ce soir dans un hôpital qui
reçoit les urgences à l'hôpital nord à
marseille
les malades sont soignés par des
internes qui malgré leurs préoccupations
qui sont dit que des préoccupations très
grave très lourde continuent à faire
leur travail font leur métier comme si
de rien n'était avec en plus marqué sur
leur blouse un badge interne en grève
donc les malades ne sont pas prises en
otage il y a à travers toute la france
une volonté de soigner les gens il n'y a
pas eu de bavure sur l'ensemble du
territoire français depuis la grève des
internes et des chefs de clinique et
nous souhaitons que cela continue par
contre nous demandons instamment à
monsieur le ministre que les problèmes
des jeunes médecins qui sont en cours de
formation et le problème des chefs de
clinique qui vont demain s'installe et
ne pâtissent pas d'une situation comme
le vide conventionnel
il est extrêmement important de ne pas
désespérer les jeunes médecins en france
car c'est l'avenir de la médecine et on
ne peut pas faire des économies de santé
sur une seule frange de la population
mais dit
gales merci hugues merci mme girard nous
allons nous rendre maintenant à rouen où
nous retrouvons toujours en direct
pierre duval au centre hospitalier
universitaire de la ville pierre tous
les médecins grévistes de haute
normandie sur le maine arpège mais pas
sur la maine note une cinquantaine
d'internautes bloquer cet après midi
pendant une heure entre 15h30 et 16h30
le péage de l'autoroute à louviers dans
l'eure ils ont observé une grève des
soins mais aussi des urgences en
revanche les chefs de clinique ont
assuré le service d'urgence il se
distingue en cela des internes et ont
probablement retenu à la vie de l'ordre
des médecins qui avait rappelé fermement
le 18 janvier dernier que les malades
doivent à tout moment recevoir les soins
qui nécessite leur état mercredi d'un an
merci excusez moi merci pierre duval
donc on revient au ministre que
répondez-vous à ce jeune médecin qui
vous pose une question à marseille que
je comprends tout à fait et leurs
angoisses des jeunes médecins
nous avons en france un nombre de
médecins sans cesse croissante qui ne
peuvent qu'être inquiet de la place
qu'ils trouveront dans leurs
installations notamment en ville ce
problème il est comme il le disait
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure il est réglée
dans le cadre de la convention médicale
qui traite donc de leur réalisation de
la médecine de ville de la médecine
libérale de ville et si il n'y a plus de
convention médicale aujourd'hui je leur
suis le premier à le regretter puisque
depuis le 1er décembre dernier les
remboursements sont assurées aux malades
sur la base simplement d'une lettre que
j'ai adressée aux caisses de sécurité
sociale leur demander leur demandant que
malgré le fait qu'il n'y avait pas de
convention médicale je leur demandais de
rembourser les malades mais cette
situation ne peut naturellement pas se
pérenniser tous les internes nous écoute
en ce moment en direct avec attention et
les téléspectateurs ont découvert avec
effarement hier dans un reportage du
19/20 le montant du revenu des médecins
bac +10 vie mille francs et on dit que
vingt mille médecins sont dans ce cas
parce qu'à part il est toujours très
très dans l'écouté il est toujours très
très difficile d'aborder ce problème
on a du mal abordé le problème de
l'argent en france malheureusement c'est
pas tout à fait les chiffres
d'abord je voudrais dire que tous les
médecins ne sont pas logés à la même
enseigne
il ya une différence entre les médecins
généralistes et les médecins
spécialistes
il ya une différence entre les médecins
l'hôpital et les médecins en médecine
libérale
j'aurais simplement indiqué qu'un
médecin en médecine libérale
un spécialiste en médecine libérale à
une moyenne de revenus de 30 mille
francs par mois
un médecin généraliste à des revenus en
moyenne en médecine libérale toujours
qu'ils sont effectivement est férié le
groupe royer ou dépend aussi des
spécialités ne simplifions pas les
problèmes
cela n'arrange pas du tout le débat vous
ne croyez pas ce qu'on appelle la
prolétarisation du monde médical
non il ya un vrai problème qui est lié
notamment à l'évolution de la
démographie médicale et moi je
souhaiterais que nous puissions parler
nous puissions en papier avec les
syndicats médicaux ça c'est un vrai
problème mais je tiens quand même à dire
que tous les médecins ne sont pas logés
à la même enseigne que j'ai autant de
préoccupations pour les médecins
généralistes par exemple mais peut-être
plus d'ailleurs parce qu'ils sont
peut-être dans une situation encore plus
difficile 24 heures sur 24
aussi quel que soit leur lieu
d'implantation en campagne ou en ville
dans des quartiers parfois difficile en
c'est aussi ma préoccupe en un mot sur
ce conflit précisément espoir de
solution ou pain oui il ya toujours des
espoirs de solutions tous les cas je
ferai tout en ce qui me concerne pour
que cette solution arrive le plus vite
possible
merci claude evin merci d'être venu dans
ce 19 20 l'autre dossier de ce 19 ans et
l'union soviétique et l'europe de l'est
l'ébullition restent toujours très
fortes en union soviétique surtout la
détermination des azéri et sans faille
et mikhaïl gorbatchev devra peut être
composer avec eux s'il veut éviter
l'irréparable
hélène risacher espoirs de ce qu'il fait
en train d'errer arméniens des
discussions entre les deux communautés
ennemis doivent reprendre incessamment
sous l'égide d'un général soviétique
la nuit dernière ces discussions qui se
déroulent dans un poste frontière
arménien tenu par l'armée rouge de la
direction ont permis
un accord de principe sur un cessez le
feu autre signe d'apaisement entre azéri
et arménien un communiqué du mouvement
nationaliste arménien qui condamne
l'action de l'armée soviétique à bas
coût et dénonce la violation des droits
souverains des azerbaïdjanais
mais si le front de la guerre entre
arméniens et azéris ans de se calmer à
bas coûts la situation demeure très
tendue
la ville est paralysée par une grève
générale et la nuit dernière des soldats
soviétiques en patrouille ont été
attaqués croit mort ce soir le kgb lance
un avertissement
l'azerbaïdjan est au bord du loup prêt à
sombrer dans le chaos et l'anarchie
le pouvoir central migraient gorbatchev
garde pour l'instant le silence face à
l'ultimatum lancé par les nationalistes
avaient ri si le menacent en effet de
déclarer l'indépendance de la république
si demain les troupes soviétiques
intervenus à bas coûts n'ont pas dégagé
dans cette partie de bras de fer
le numéro un soviétique de se préparer à
composer avec les nationalistes et
azerbaïdjan sous peine de voir l'union
soviétique partir en lambeaux
l'azerbaïdjan vous le savez réclame son
indépendance la constitution soviétique
permettra-t-elle à cette république de
réaliser son souhait est de prendre ses
distances à l'égard de moscou
la réponse de mémona hintermann
légalement l'azerbaïdjan a le droit de
quitter lempire le droit d'être
indépendant et souverain
l'article 72 de la constitution
soviétique le stipule cette nuit
l'ultimatum des indépendantistes azuri
expire
si l'armée ne se retire pas d'ici ir
examineront des deux mains à leurs
unions d'églises hausse face à cette
menace
mikhaïl gorbatchev est démuni
juridiquement lors de son voyage en
lituanie le 11 janvier dernier
l'énumération meetic a lui même reconnu
le droit à la sécession
seulement il expliqué il faut savoir
comment et dans quelles conditions qui
tellure carte il dit est les problèmes
de défense et des communications un
argument astucieux pour gagner du temps
question gorbatchev pour at-il assez de
temps pour éviter l'écroulement de son
empire
gorbatchev se trouve dans une situation
paradoxale l'homme qui a initié la
pérestroïka suivi de lourdes difficultés
dans son propre pays alors que dans les
pays voisins les résultats sont encore
plus rapides qu'ils ne l'espéraient les
élections générales auront lieu le 20
mai prochain en roumanie sous le
contrôle des nations unies
quant à la hongrie elle peut se montrer
vraiment satisfaite aujourd'hui elle a
obtenu de moscou un retrait des troupes
soviétiques
morad aït habbouche octobre 56 l'armée
rouge écrase insurrections populaires
hongroises
aujourd'hui plus de 33 ans après miklos
nemeth le premier ministre confirme
devant le parlement
la volonté de son pays désormais il n'y
a aucune raison politique ou militaire
pour que les troupes soviétiques reste
ici et il ajoute nos forces ont
parfaitement capable de défendre tout
seul l'intégrité territoriale et notre
souveraineté
la hongrie l urss sont donc tombés
d'accord ce matin le retrait sera totale
à l'heure actuelle 52 mille soldats
soviétiques sont basés en hongrie à
premier retrait limité toutefois avait
commencé en avril 89
timmy l'homme était rentré au pays
lafleur à la kalachnikov
le reste devrait donc suivre un
calendrier sera établi souple eu une
réunion est d'ailleurs prévue à budapest
avec les experts militaires du kremlin
reste que michael gorbatchev n'a
toujours rien promis ni à la pologne à
la tchécoslovaquie où l'armée rouge est
également présente
un seul pays restent à l'écart de ce
formidable mouvement un pays qui se
garde bien de faire parler de lui
l'albanie un pays aux frontières fermées
et où les mots démocratie et libertés ne
sont pas encore rentrés
cela vous donne une idée de l'exploit
qu'une équipe de la 3 a réalisé en se
rendant en albanie et ce qu'ont
découvert jérôme cathala
et jean-michel destin est proprement
surréaliste tout va bien en albanie
reportage 45 ans il y à 45 ans que
l'albanie avance sur la route de
l'édification du socialisme
un chemin qui l'a isolé progressivement
de l'urss de la chine et du reste de
l'europe alors l'albanie vit et
travaille en silence
même la présence d'une caméra étrangères
pourtant exceptionnel ne change rien au
comportement rares très rares seront
ceux qui viendront spontanément nous
parler la crainte peut-être mais surtout
la réserve
pas question d'émettre la plus légère
critique sur le régime sur leur pays car
aux termes de la constitution de la
république populaire socialiste
d'albanie l'état c'est eux les 3
millions d'albanais acquis tout
appartient collectivement les terres les
maisons les usines
comment ce pays enfermés entre ses
montagnes et ses certitudes at il
ressenti les événements intervenus en
europe de l'est
une question que nous avons posée
partout en albanie au changement ont
éveillé de vives discussions parmi les
ouvriers et notre parti et le camarade
d'enver hodja nous avait prévenus dans
les années 60 que de tels changements
auraient lieu
c'est le résultat de la restauration du
capitalisme dans ces pays je suis désolé
et déçu des événements en europe de
l'est
mais je suis surtout indignée du bain de
sang roumanie des pays de l'est ne se
sont jamais vraiment engagée dans la
voie du socialisme tracé par marx et
engels l'albanie elle n'a jamais dévié
réelle ou feinte cette unanimité touche
toutes les couches de la population et
certains vont encore plus loin dans
l'illustration et la défense du régime
nous les jeunes serions prêts à
descendre dans la rue si le gouvernement
touche et au socialisme
car nous sommes heureux grâce au
socialisme mais je pense que ça
n'arrivera pas apparemment le héros de
la libération en verre aux jo n'est pas
près de se retourner dans sa tombe
apparemment donc l'albanie ressemble
toujours à une forteresse
ça me fait penser à ce que l'on
entendait dans les pays de l'est avant
la révolution
tout va bien disait-il at on une chance
d'entendre autre chose demain après
demain en albanie jérôme bien
effectivement c'est la question par une
question je dirais même une question
piège puisque il faut être clair est
clair dès maintenant ce que nous avons
vu jean michel d'estanguet mois en
albanie nous avons pu le voir parce que
les autorités albanaises ont bien voulu
nous le montrer autant dire que nous
étions accompagnés par deux trois voire
quatre accompagnateurs officielle de la
télévision albanaise nous avons tout de
même pu sillonner le pays de part en
part
je crois que l'on peut être affirmatif
sur un point il n'y a pas pour l'instant
de mouvements de troupes ni de
renforcement policiers autour des
domiciles des hauts dignitaires ou
autour des bâtiments administratifs
cela dit derrière ce calme que vous avez
peut-être pu saisir dans notre reportage
il y a des difficultés et les
difficultés surtout parmi la minorité
grecque orthodoxe qui se trouvent dans
le sud du pays
sans doute est ce là le ferment de
futurs troubles éventuels en albanie
merci jérôme en france procès des deux
policiers accusés d'avoir frappé à mort
malik oussékine élise lucet a suivi la
seconde journée
elle raconte 15h30 cet après midi le
brigadier schmitt hésite il bafouille se
reprend et regarde par terre depuis plus
de deux heures maintenant
le président de la cour d'assises
l'interrogent sans relâche sur ses faits
et gestes dans les minutes qui ont
précédé la mort de malik oussékine smit
fronce les sourcils il se crispe et
devant l'insistance et la précision des
questions il s'énerve même à ce moment
là j'étais groggy affirme le brigadier
je venais de prendre un pavé en pleine
poitrine je ne me souviens plus très
bien ce qui est arrivé
passé le feu des questions du président
ferret
c'est le ministère public qui prend le
relais depuis le début de l'audience
suit l'affirment haut et fort je ne suis
jamais entré dans le hall du 20 rue
monsieur le prince
j ai juste vu certains de mes hommes il
y avait du remue ménage moi j'avais un
malaise questions de l'avocat général
comment expliquez vous alors que votre
première audition le 6 décembre 86 soit
totalement contradictoire au moins en
deux points
silence du brigadier schmitt trouble
dans la salle d'audience l'inculpé a
grip la barre du box des accusés
maître kiejman porte l'estocade ils
posent de nouvelles questions plus
précises encore le ton monte parfois
puis redevient insistant à trois
reprises lors de cette audience cet
après midi schmidt se contredit dans ses
déclarations très calme maître kiejman
triomphe avec humour
vous venez de vous contredire cela doit
être un lapsus d'autres nouvelles du
jour avec nathalie darrigrand un
pilotage près de montpellier tourne au
drame une femme de 43 ans est morte deux
hommes ont été grièvement blessés lors
du hold up de cette agence de placement
financier peu après la fusillade le
forcené un homme d'origine allemande
s'est rendu à la police
fois c'est la guerre entre le maire de
la ciotat et la société lectra jean
pierre lafon acheter cash et pour 45
millions de francs
la totalité des bâtiments des chantiers
navals 43 hectares de sites sur lesquels
se trouve le domaine promis à la société
américaine aux suédoises résultat la
lexmark qui a commencé la remise en état
de la ciotat le dispose ce soir ni de
l'outillage du site ni des locaux
indiscrétions dans la sphère du meurtre
de david cyr ou un mineur aurait été
inculpé d'homicide involontaire en
décembre dernier du fait de son âge la
loi interdit toute révélation concernant
son identité
une information qui privilégie la thèse
de l'accident à l'époque le ferrailleur
robert cyr ou et son autre fils avait
violemment accusé le propriétaire de
leur cas ce rallye de monte carlo une
épreuve très mouvementée aujourd'hui
didier auriol sur l'ancien a remporté la
dernière spéciale en début de soirée il
avait auparavant cédé le commandement à
l'espagnol carlos sainz sur toyota mais
il se replace en tête du classement
général
alain dorgans résume l'étape une
bataille sans merci a opposé aujourd'hui
entre gap et monaco les deux favoris du
rallye de monte carlo
auriol et side l épreuve commune s'est
soldée par le plus intime des écarts 4
secondes en faveur d'auriol pour les
deux pilotes retour à la case départ
après avoir concédé deux secondes lors
de la première spéciale l'espagnol
carlos sainz sur toyota a soufflé la
première place à son éternel rival en
début d'après-midi à châteauvieux au
départ de la dernière épreuve
très arrive appaméenne récent vainqueur
du paris-dakar abandonne sur panne de
moteur de sa mitsubishi
cette dernière spéciale du col de bleine
remportée par didier auriol sur l'ennui
a permis aux français de rentrer en 7 à
monaco avec seulement quatre secondes
d'avancé sur l'espagnol
demain soir le mano à mano entre orioli
signs connaîtra son apothéose dans soir
le suspense regard d'homme sur la haute
couture filière easy bélair aujourd'hui
robert sabatier il découvre pour la
première fois de sa vie le rituel des
collections cet après midi channel vous
inviter à venir voir une collection avec
vous pour le plaisir de l'initier
tardivement à l'un des rites les plus
voluptueuses moins éphémère qui soit les
quelques robes qui l'a inventé le foot
que des mots pour héroïne de roman et
les mots jetés sur un programme par le
couturier du style on peut adulé
l'acidulé mais les couleurs sont modulés
le font d'emblée éclaté très joyeux noé
but il y avait un tel brouhaha je
croyais être un match de boxe mais c'est
infiniment plus gracieux
y en a qui me font peur un peu celle oui
quand elles ont un air sévère est résolu
à voilà la jolie petite brigitte bardot
pas c'est joli ce noir et rose super
les amis dont 3 je fais dans la fente
coluche mais en fait je crois que c'est
du grand art c'est amusant mais fait
quand j'étais enfant et que je voyais
pas dans vos cinémas aux actualités des
présentations de haute couture tout le
monde rigolait ça s'est souvent
exagérément ridicule là c'est chamelle
édicules plus rien ne vit plus rien ne
bouge lorsque paraît la femme en rouge
doit être nul tout ce que je dis
n'importe quel match audois dire ça la
banda on résiste pas on impose tout de
suite
tricheur elle est déjà au creux d'une
page vierge
vous avez reconnu la belle voix
d'elizabeth qu'il ait des gens qui a
servi de guide à robert sabatier dont le
prochain roman sortira le 3 février chez
albin michel la souris verte
faut-il avoir des muscles pour devenir
ministre en posera la question à
monsieur bambuck george bush aux états
unis vient de nommer arnold
schwarzenegger président du conseil de
la forme et des sports le regard de
femme caroline since
e
avez vous déjà vu un homme politique
aussi bien roulé certainement pas au
gouvernement français ou alors ils se
cachent
celui là il est aux usa et cdh george
bush qui l'a choisi il les aime blond et
bien musclé il en a fait son aigre noir
schwarzeneger un autrichien à la maison
blanche de quoi faire hurler tous les
[ __ ] de new york
mais voilà à eux ils n'ont pas la
mâchoire carrée et le muscle saillant
d'arnold un joli petit nom pour être
président du conseil pour la forme
physique et les sports
les américains ont le crois sont
carrément maso
car avec arnold ça ne rigole pas
schwarzenegger et ses 98 kg de muscles
sans compter la cervelle sentent au
pouvoir george bush n'a qu'a bien
s'accrocher
une petite tape et schwartz ou l'envoie
au tapis après tout un cowboy est bien
devenu président des usa fin de ce 19 20
ce soir soir 3 présenté par marc
hautement dans quelques secondes le
temps avec florence qu'un bon soir à
demain